Hello everybody and welcome back to the
channel. I'm trying to squeeze this
video in before I head off to Vegas
tomorrow. So, if next week I don't make
a video, it's probably because I gambled
off uh my camera or uh my house even.
So, uh this could be the last one ever
on JHNL and uh if it is so long. But for
now, let's go ahead and talk about
Twitter search. Twitter search is a
problem that is fairly simple to
understand. At its core, we want to be
able to perform keyword-based search
over all tweets that have been made.
Twitter exposes a couple of different
views when searching for posts. One of
them displays the latest tweets matching
your search. The other exposes the top
post matching a search, which is
typically by the number of likes or
views on it, perhaps combined with some
recency factor. Let's expose two main
pieces of functionality here. The first
is going to be searching all posts based
on some keyword terms and displaying the
latest results. The other is going to be
searching posts based on keyword terms,
but this time applying a scoring system
that ranks posts based on their
popularity. In 2010, one of the Twitter
founders was quoted saying that Twitter
receives 800 million search queries per
day, which equates to 10,000 per second.
They also receive 500 million tweets per
day, which is closer to 6,000 per
second. If each tweet is a kilobyte,
we're storing close to 2 pabytes of data
in a decade. We'll need to index this to
fetch this data quickly and also be able
to address a huge volume of queries.
We'll certainly need tens if not
hundreds of nodes for this purpose and
we'll have to figure out how to scale
our index accordingly. If you haven't
watched the video in the series about
how the Twitter news feed works, you
should. Nonetheless, let's go over the
relevant parts of it here. When a user
creates a tweet, we ultimately need to
deliver it to all of their followers in
a read optimized way. To do that, we
ensure that our tweet makes it into a
durable message broker like Kafka. That
way, we can eventually use a fleet of
consumers to fan it out to a variety of
databases. After that, each user only
has to pull a single database shard to
fetch their newsfeed as opposed to
reading from all shards of the tweets
database. Another topic that we covered
in this series was about the Facebook
like button, which we can assume works
in a similar manner to the one on
Twitter. Recall that certain posts can
get very popular and synchronously
trying to increment an atomic like
counter for these posts can lead to a
lot of database contention. Instead, we
have opted to use a source of truth
likes per user table which was evenly
load balanced using the user ID as the
partition key. We then used change data
capture and background processing to
maintain a derived data table which
maintained a like count per post ID.
We'll eventually be utilizing some of
the infrastructure that we built out in
both these videos, so it's important to
have a good grasp on these. If you
haven't realized by now that you should
probably be watching this series in
order, I'm now going to reference
another concept that we covered in the
Yelp design video. When you want to
perform searches based on keywords,
doing naive text matching is pretty
inefficient. Instead, you want to employ
something known as a search index. In
the Yelp video, we used a Postgress
database to do this. However, in this
one, we'll choose a technology that
makes scaling out search indexes a
little bit easier. Elastic search is a
distributed search index built on top of
a technology known as Lucen. Simply put,
each elastic search node is a Lucine
index and you can build clusters of many
of these nodes. Not only does Lucine
maintain an inverted index for fast
keyword searches, it can do a lot more,
which we'll cover later in this video.
At the core of this problem, we need to
think about the inverted index. Up to
this point, I've basically always said,
try and partition your data in a way
that minimizes the number of nodes that
you write to and read from. However,
this becomes trickier in a problem like
this one. Let's think about some
approaches. Keep in mind that we want to
optimize our read path. This means that
when a query comes in, searching for all
posts with the term toes, it would be
great if all of the document IDs
containing it lived on a single shard.
This concept is known as term
partitioning. However, there are some
significant trade-offs to this, too.
When I post a tweet, it has hundreds of
words in it. That means that on every
single write, I potentially have to send
data to hundreds of different nodes,
each one holding a particular search
term. Another downside here is load
balancing. Certain terms are extremely
popular compared to others, and a small
percentage of words are in the vast
majority of tweets. We'd probably have
to do further sharding even beyond this
term-based partitioning, which
complicates things a lot. Finally, most
search queries actually need to hit many
shards anyways. If I search for the term
Jordan sips Corin's bathwater, I may
need to send that query to five shards,
one per word. For these reasons, most
search indexes don't actually support
term-based partitioning. Instead, they
opt for document partitioning where
documents are sent to a particular shard
based on the hash of their document ID.
That's what happens in Elastic Search.
There's one major downside of this. When
you query elastic search, you need to
read from every single shard. This means
that your query speed is equal to the
response time of the slowest one.
Fortunately, one aspect of search that
isn't typical with your OLTP database is
that incomplete results are often
acceptable. Elastic Search actually
allows you to set a timeout on a query
after which point it will return
whatever data it's aggregated so far.
Then we can support a bounded request
latency. While it doesn't seem to be
explicitly supported by elastic search,
another common way of splitting up data
is to use timebased partitioning. You
can just create multiple indexes, one
for each bucket of time that you want to
split data across. This is really common
amongst things like logs where you
typically know in advance which date you
want to search for. We may even be able
to use a system like this to help
isolate our most recent tweets from
others, thereby ensuring that searches
for recent posts are very fast. Given
the volume of requests that we're
handling, we'll likely need to be able
to serve reads from many different
nodes. Fortunately, Elastic Search
supports this concept via replication.
Each shard can have multiple readonly
replicas which are updated
asynchronously. That lack of consistency
is really not a big deal for search. It
also performs automatic failover across
shards in the event that one of them
goes down. Another open question one may
have here is where to actually store the
documents. In theory, an inverted index
could just contain a mapping of terms to
document IDs. This would keep the size
of each elastic search shard much
smaller as well as allow it to serve
less data back to the client. Keep in
mind, however, that each tweet is only a
kilobyte to store. We can pretty much
comfortably fit many billions of these
on a single node. If we need our
newsfeed reads to be denormalized to be
sufficiently fast, we should probably be
doing the same thing in our search
index. Given the fact that we're storing
actual tweet data in Elastic Search,
perhaps we want to occasionally purge
post data from our index to ensure our
cluster doesn't grow to pabytes in size,
we can run a batch job on an interval
that deletes old unpopular posts. Since
we only support searching for either new
posts or popular posts, these should
never really be reflected anyways. In
addition to doing keyword search for
posts, elastic search also allows us to
define multiple ranking functions that
we can use to impact how it orders posts
during a query. This way, if we upload
the number of likes on a post, we can
write logic to combine this with the
post recency and the actual quality of
keyword matches in order to compute a
score. By using this function as well as
another based on the post creation
timestamp, we can ensure that each
lucine index knows how to compute the
top posts and the latest posts for a
given keyword query. Up to this point,
we've mainly spoken about how we can
serve fast reads from our distributed
search index. What we need to discuss
now is how to get data in there in the
first place. Typically, when it comes to
search indexes, inserting data is
actually pretty expensive. This is
because in addition to taking in the
body of the tweet, the node has to
actually parse the contents to add it
into the lucine index. For that reason,
Elastic Search recommends batching
writes as much as possible, which
reduces network overhead when sending
data to the cluster. For inserting
tweets, we can read from our tweets
Kafka Q. Recall that every newly created
tweet goes into this. We can set up a
Kafka consumer group to handle these
messages. They'll take in the tweets and
every couple of seconds make a call to
Elastic Search to bulk upsert those
documents. In theory, it would be great
if each consumer was only uploading
records to a single shard of Elastic
Search. However, this would require a
few different things to be true. First
off, the Kafka Q for tweets would need
to have the same number of partitions as
the number of shards in our elastic
search index. Secondly, our Kafka Q
would need to be partitioned based on
the hash of the tweet ID. And then
finally, we'd have to use the same exact
hash function to partition both Kafka
and Elastic Search. While this sounds
really great when we're speaking about
it, in practice, these are separate
layers of our system, and we probably
want to allow them all to scale
independently. In addition to getting
the actual post data into our search
index, we also need to ensure that like
counts are up to date on each post.
Fortunately, we have a table that is
keeping track of the like counts on each
one. We can register a change data feed
into another Kafka topic from our postl
like counts table, allowing us to bulk
upsert tweets with an updated count.
Let's go over this flow al together.
When a user submits or edits a tweet, it
goes into our tweets Kafka Q, which is
partitioned on tweet ID. From there, we
have a Kafka consumer group pulling from
this list and upserting data into our
search index every few seconds. Because
we're using upserts, we don't have to
worry about exactly once processing from
our consumers. As long as they process
every message at least once, each write
to the search index is item potent and
we'll be good to go. We have a similar
process going when users like a tweet.
We have a separate pipeline which
capitulates and writes to a table that
keeps track of a like count per post. By
subscribing to a change feed from here,
we can easily get each post's current
number of likes and update that in
elastic search. We'll subscribe to the
change data with a coffee consumer group
which will look very similar to our
process for handling incoming tweets. We
can run a batch job once per day that
looks for old tweets that have very few
likes and removes them from our index.
This keeps the volume of documents to
store down and also ensures that queries
on each individual node remain faster as
they have less data to sift through.
Today we're going to talk a little bit
about semantic search. While this is
definitely a topic for another video,
let's do a shallow overview here. I'm
calling this a deep dive because I
imagine that it might be considered a
bit above and beyond for your typical
systems design interview. I could be
totally wrong and in a few years from
now, this statement will probably age
really poorly. The concept of a word
embedding is the idea that a word can be
represented as a vector of many numbers.
Similar words would have similar
vectors. Words might even be represented
by multiple vectors. For example, when
I'm talking about the word cheeks, you
have no clue whether I'm talking about
the ones on my face, which are very soft
and luscious, or the ones on Karinaop's
posterior, which are also surprisingly
pretty luscious looking. Computing word
embeddings is a machine learning problem
in itself. But the idea is that by using
a large set of training data and looking
at the context in which we use each
word, we can figure out how to represent
them as vectors. When somebody searches
for a Twitter post, they don't typically
care about the exact keyword matches,
but more likely just want to get the
essence of what they mean. If I'm
searching for a post with monkeys
smoking cigarettes, I'm not going to be
super disappointed if I see a tweet
showing chimpanzees ripping cigars.
Since these two terms would likely have
similar vectors, what we really care
about is representing my search term as
a vector and then finding out all the
posts that have the most similar vector
representation. This implies that we
need to be able to figure out a vector's
nearest neighbor super quickly and over
a really large set of vectors.
Fortunately, there are now databases
that help us do this called vector
databases. As I'm sure you can imagine,
vector databases are special because
they allow you to find the nearest
neighbors of a vector very quickly. This
isn't an easy problem. If you think
about our geospatial index, reducing a
multi-dimensional space into something
that's easily searchable is not trivial.
I won't go into them too much at the
moment, but vector databases usually
perform indexing over vectors using one
or more of these three algorithms.
Hierarchical navigable small worlds,
inverted file, and product quantization.
While I do hope to eventually make
videos on all three of these, they're
out of scope for today. Thanks everyone
for stopping by. Uh I appreciate the
view. Hopefully you learned something as
well. Uh I should be around next week
for another one as long as I don't get
caught in Reno this weekend. If I do,
it's over for me. But let's assume that
doesn't happen. I'll see you guys soon.